all right Josie hi Josie uh where are
you from where'd you grow up I'm from
mid city Los Angeles I grew up right
down the street from Fairfax and Venice
in an area I think it's technically
called the karthay square and tell me
about your family growing up
um
I would say my family life was pretty
normal
um my dad was very present for my
childhood
um I have a really cool mom she's
sort of friends with the realm of
psychedelics so I would say that that
aspect of her parenting really
influenced me even though as a child I
didn't know about her experimentation
with psychedelics
um it wasn't something we really
discussed until I got older and
experimented with it in my own ways
um but I think just her very like nature
prone elements really helped me develop
as a person
um sounds like a good childhood it was a
good childhood you know he had a house I
had a backyard I was able to play in
um
I yeah my family was fine growing up I
have issues with my dad now and we don't
really talk
um but in my really developmental stages
I don't think that impacted me too
heavily which I'm really grateful for
that's great yeah
what kind of kid are you in high school
I was an angsty [ __ ] high school I
was sort of um
just kind of hated everything I mostly
hated myself and that made me hate
everything
um I really struggled with myself in
high school
um I struggled with self-harm from a
young age and that really impacted my
um my like social skills I really
struggled with social anxiety
and depression and I have since a young
age
um so high school was just a very
tumultuous time for me I was super super
depressed my grades were awful
um I was friends with an interesting
group of people in school for sure a
very alternative group I later learned
that our school referred to us as like
the group of witches at our school I
went to South Pasadena High
um
and that was a really interesting
environment to be in as well
um because it's sort of a prestigious
school as far as semi-public schools go
yeah
it's a wealthier neighborhood it is
there's a lot of doctors and lawyers in
that neighborhood but it's just funny
because most of their kids are on drugs
on the weekend and so that was a really
interesting like dichotomy to sort of
grow up in I feel like I developed a lot
in high school and towards the end of
high school by the time I was 16 that's
when I started engaging with things like
mushrooms and LSD and that just kind of
completely turned everything around for
me it really helped with my depression
and anxiety I realized I was really
beautiful and powerful
and that I had a certain draw to me that
I just didn't know that I had before and
that was a really empowering experience
for me so high school started off really
rough and finished well I actually left
South Pasadena to do independent studies
where my grades just sort of skyrocketed
and I found myself really able to
socialize and just feeling really
connected with myself and the world
and that just sort of yeah changed my
trajectory and your credit uh
psychedelics partially for changing that
hugely psychedelics and my best friend
from high school Caitlyn she really just
influenced me and sort of opened me up
to
realizing that like life isn't so
horrifying all the time and it doesn't
need to be taken so seriously
um yeah she really just like taught me
how to love and so I would say her the
psychedelics and just you know other
elements of my life maybe maturing a
little bit too yeah so maturing
definitely
um teenage years are hard teenagers are
hard I mean teenagers are going through
so much and we just you know we don't
we take ourselves too seriously as we're
teenagers and I think that makes adults
want to take us less seriously because
of how like deep in our own [ __ ] we are
um
and uh
yeah and so just the maturing experience
of realizing like I don't have to Hate
Everything I can enjoy something and
that's okay and angstiness is not you
know the answer it's not beautiful to be
[ __ ] mad all the time
um yeah it matured me a lot how old are
you now I am 23. yeah I'll be 24 at the
end of this month so what what kind of
career
directions that you want to go in
um right now I am interested in cannabis
I just completed a six-month course
online through an extension program of
green flower media and so I got a
certification for business and cannabis
from seed to sale and I'm interested to
see what I can do with that
you're currently working as a
but I'm currently a stripper I work at a
topless bar I've been dancing for about
a year and three months I think
um
and so far it's my favorite job I've had
you enjoy it yeah I've worked a lot of
different jobs
um I've done a lot of Bud tending my
first job was nannying which is pretty
typical
um and then once I was actually able to
legally work I worked in a bookstore I
was the lunch lady in my high school
I worked at another bookstore I've
worked at a couple different
dispensaries I worked at a cupcake shop
I've been a housekeeper
I've done a lot of stuff I've been a
personal assistant two different times
but yeah dancing's my favorite I find
the most autonomy through dancing
um what are the things you like about it
I like that I'm able to do what I want
um for them within reason
um
I struggle a lot like I said with
anxiety and depression my mental health
has been
just a huge ride of my whole life
um and this is like the job where I'm
very much so allowed to move with my
intuition I don't have to show up if I
don't want to if I wake up one day and I
just can't go I don't have to go
um it can take breaks whenever I need to
I struggle a lot with chronic pain as
well and my lower back I had a couple of
repeat injuries in the gym and in a car
crash so there's some days where being
on the floor standing all day I just
can't do it I start to break down
towards the end of the day and so what's
nice about dancing is that when my
body's capped it's capped I can go home
or I can just sit down until I feel
better again or I can take three to four
days off if I really need like a
therapeutic rest period And there's just
not another job I've had where I had the
same freedoms
and tell me about the guys that come in
and how they treat you
for the most part they're pretty much
run-of-the-mill guys
um and it's funny I feel like men on the
street they can't call you they harass
you they try to grab you
and the men in the club kind of all try
to pretend that they don't do that
um they come in with this like really a
lot of the times a really respectful
demeanor
um especially now with the amount of
like
a sort of online the amount of heat
words that are going around with like in
you know with intersectional feminism
and just being like aware of the
patriarchy and all that you know men
come in with these sort of like
rehearsed lines now about how much they
respect women and I think it's really
funny
um
uh there's always you know disrespectful
guys guys that try to slap your ass
after giving you a single dollar
um and those are definitely my least
favorite guys but they're also really
fun to sort of mess around with because
um I can you can end up working those
guys and make them realize like a dollar
doesn't cut it that's not how this works
um I had one guy once
that on my first like week or two at the
club I currently work at where we were
just sitting having a conversation and
he just pulled my he like pulled the
string on my bikini top and took it down
and I don't usually feel violated by men
in this industry but
um I did buy that and I really hated
that
um
but that was the only guy that ever like
really did something that I was just
like that is just blatant disrespect off
top
um
and uh I just walked away I went home
after that like pretty much immediately
so there's guys like that
um
a lot of men are sort of trying to flex
their wealth or compensate for their
insecurities
um the strip club is the one place they
can go and choose a woman you know they
don't get to do that on the streets
they're constantly trying to get your
attention
um and uh and when they go into the club
they're allowed to have it be reversed
and they're allowed to you know say oh I
don't want you you're not what I'm
looking for and I think some men
definitely get a certain pleasure out of
that and if that's you know that's their
thing that's their thing that's fine
um there's also men that just come in
and they just want to make it rain and
treat you right and send you home happy
and those are my favorite
I mean I'm sure the amount of money
you'll make will range quite a bit
yeah what do you make on a good night
um the best day I work in the daytime
I'm a daytime stripper
um the best day I've had I took home
fourteen hundred dollars
um it was great it was great
um yeah I think the one of the hardest
parts actually about dancing is how much
people don't realize it's not easy money
it's just fast money
um but some days there's just no money
there's been plenty of days where I left
paying out of pocket
um after being in the club for four to
five hours and just not making any money
and then there's days where I'm like
non-stop going around and I'm like the
hot topic of the day and everybody wants
a dance for me and I can rack it up and
it's great
um what what dictates that
a lot of it is the environment of the
club for the day a lot of it is where I
am mentally and physically and where
I've like Met Myself That Day some days
my insecurities really take over and I
just stick to the stage because I feel
maybe too nervous to go talk to people
and then there's days where I just feel
like a firecracker I'm full of energy
I'm feeling really friendly and social
and talking to people just feels like
second nature and so I can really bounce
around and you know work every angle on
the floor so your attitude your energy
yeah can drive how much money you make
yeah that impacts it a lot does alcohol
or drugs help you
not improve your your attitude it
doesn't actually which I'm really
grateful for I have a lot of friends who
struggle with managing their alcohol
consumption or drug consumption
and that's just never really been an
issue for me when I was younger and I
was into psychedelics I really had a
period where I didn't feel myself unless
I was doing psychedelics and so I found
myself every weekend wanting to take
acid with my friends and or you know
um
MDMA or sassafras or mushrooms and I
just really felt this strong need to
just feel out of my body but also super
in control of it at the same time
um I went to therapy for that and it
helped I also just did a lot of like
self-reflection and that helped and I
think that helped me not that helped
retroactively or proactively helped me
down the line
um
I've never really been that into
drinking I really like to smoke weed I
smoke weed every day but I'm not
dysfunctional if I don't smoke weed
um but yeah drinking at the club I drive
myself there and back so even if I am
drinking I have to be dead Sober by 6 37
so that helps as well
but also I just don't enjoy being drunk
that much I like being tipsy I think
it's fun but being drunk and messy and
like not fully in control of my body is
not something that I enjoy which I'm
grateful for
and romantic relationships are those
even possible while you're working at a
club like this um they're not impossible
I've been in a long-term romantic
relationship
um
you know it was
I was already with him when I started
dancing
um and that you know took work for us to
for both parties to be comfortable with
the changes
um
but yeah it's not impossible so your
your boyfriend will he's okay with what
happens at the club sometimes
yeah I mean he doesn't have much
experience going to strip clubs he's not
really like your guy's hands or guys
hands yeah at the club he really
struggled with that and I sort of just
broke it down for him you know I was
just like I feel nothing for these men
I'm not you know I'm not horny at the
club I know a lot of girls do get horny
at the club but for me being turned on
or into something is sort of
circumstantial and it requires intimacy
for me to be turned on
um and so I'm not a hypersexual person
there's not much of a risk of me being
you know
you know like taken away by some man at
the club
um and I'm pretty controlling about how
men are allowed to touch me at the club
too so you know it's not like you're
getting finger bangs in the back do you
get guys that offer
try try to get more from you than with
what you're offering every single day oh
yeah every day
um what do they say to you
they're like oh I'll pay you five
thousand dollars to come with me or I'll
pay whatever you want to come with me
I'll give you a free apartment if you
like want to be my sugar baby stuff like
that
um is that tempting for a young girl
I mean sometimes the idea of being like
Oh if you didn't have a boyfriend right
I mean the idea of like oh I don't have
to worry about financial stuff that
sounds awesome
um
I've had experience with sugar babying
in the past it's not something that's
like foreign to me
um that was before my relationship
and even then I just sort of saw it as
like sugar-coated escorting
um a lot of the time the guys you meet
there they just want to see you one time
and never see you again so I I feel I
have like mixed feelings around that
type of stuff I guess I never like found
the right person when I was trying to
look for that
um
wait I mean you were looking for what
you were I was pursuing sugar daddy you
were in a way yeah two websites and
things like that yeah there was a
website I was part of
um
and uh
but yeah it was just weird these guys
were fishy
um and I just never trusted any of them
enough to like you know really want to
pursue or be pursued by them
um is there no getting away from the
the simple fact that women are looking
for security and men are looking for an
attractive female men are looking for
women
um yeah but a lot of women find security
in themselves and they don't need a man
for that and I think that's actually a
really beautiful thing that working as a
stripper has really helped me to realize
is that there are all these women around
me who
are just making [ __ ] work for themselves
so many women I work with have kids and
maybe started dancing after their kids
or started dancing before and even
danced up to like six months into their
pregnancy
um but like security
isn't always just about you know money
there's there's feelings when it comes
to security too and I don't think that
somebody just providing you unlimited
amounts of money is necessarily security
but I know that's a really like loaded
thing to say because I know for a lot of
people security just is money and for me
in a lot of ways it really is just money
um but sort of through this I've
realized like I might not be rich I'm a
stripper I have been for over a year but
strippers aren't always rich or like
rolling in money I've been I've at some
points of dancing I've struggled
financially harder than I have when I've
had stable jobs
um but the feelings that I've gotten
from myself and realizing how much I've
learned about myself that's provided me
security and that's provided me tools
that I can take into the rest of my life
to keep myself secure and to keep myself
stable and safe yeah just working as a
topless dancer help your
self-esteem or your confidence
yeah some days it really does and some
days it tears it down
um
let's see I really struggled with my
body image my whole life
um I actually wanted to be a dancer from
a young age which I know is
non-conventional
um but like what how young in age I one
time one night my mom was watching City
Island and there's the scene towards the
end of the movie where the daughter
reveals to her parents that she's a
stripper and I asked my mom I said what
is a stripper why are her parents so mad
about that and she goes a stripper is a
person who takes their clothes off and
dances and they get paid for it and I
was just like hold the phone
like you can get paid to get naked and
dance I was like I want to do that
um
for somebody who's so like who's
struggled with body image so much I've
always wanted to just be naked even if
I've hated my body my my comfort my area
of comfort has usually been nudity
um
and uh so finding out that there was a
job out there where like you can get
paid to just to be to reveal Yourself to
Dance to entertain people I really
wanted to try that
um and I know that sounds like really
privileged to be like oh I wanted to be
a dancer
um and I recognize how it is but I think
it's also really important to know that
there are people who are strippers by
choice it's not just a last resort it's
a really valid way to make money and
it's especially valid if you struggle
with things like your mental Wellness or
your time schedule like if you have
children
um and so
um
yeah it hugely helped with my body
confidence I really wanted to start
dancing as soon as I turned 18 but I
just felt like oh no I'm not at the
right place yet my body isn't right yet
my body isn't right yet and I said that
for years and then once I turned 21
I was kind of just sick of it I was sick
of myself I was sick of not doing what I
said I wanted to do and I was really
really sick of being harassed by Men At
my dispensary job or whatever my Cafe
job whatever it was my personal
assisting job
um I just realized there were men around
me every single day wanting saying to my
face they wish they could see what was
under my clothes pointing out that they
could see my nipples through my shirt
all these things and for minimum wage
and I was just like okay now I'm done
with this and I said it doesn't matter
where my body's at I can my body can
always change
but what's more important is my
circumstances changing and so I just
went and I went to do my audition
at the first Club I worked at which was
a full nude club in Oregon
and after my interview with the owner he
didn't even he wasn't even worried about
seeing me dance he wasn't worried about
seeing my body he just knew that I was
going to be good at it and so he told me
to come back on Saturday and I came back
on Saturday
and
um I was shocked by how comfortable I
was when I took my clothes off for the
first time
um and a friend of strangers yeah and it
felt great I loved it and
um and I realized I was really good at
it so it helped a lot and it I really
realized that like
there might be these idealized body
types there may be you know stereotypes
of what a
um what a sexual Entertainer looks like
um but there is no one mold that people
are attracted to there's not just one
thing that everybody likes
um and I realize people really like me
and I've had I've my body weights
fluctuated a lot over the last year and
a half in the time I have danced and
I've been adored at every stage of that
as well
um and it's just never I realize it's
just not as much of a as a problem it's
not something as scary as I thought it'd
be and it really helped me to like
accept and love my body
and now I just I really do love my body
and I'm really grateful to be in it even
when it gives me problems I think it's
important for especially women to
understand that
like you have an image of your head with
in your head what you should look like
yeah but you could be much heavier or
lighter or thinner whatever and there's
going to be somebody for every body type
for everybody that thinks you're the
greatest thing that ever walked through
exactly and that's the end also because
women in general are the greatest things
to walk the earth you know I worship
women I love women
um and
we are the greatest things to walk the
earth period that's just what it is
that's why these men that's why men are
so obsessed with with conquering us or
whatever it is you know it's because we
are almost inherently unobtainable even
when we are in relationships or when we
are in you know strip clubs whatever it
is we are still our own people we cannot
fully be had
um and I think that's really special and
I think that's a power it's like a
superpower it's a secret weapon and I
think I think a lot more women could
stand to realize that about themselves
it's great that you understand this at
23.
what do you think most women don't
understand about themselves about being
a woman oh my heart breaks by how much
people around me hate themselves
um there are women you know that will go
on stage and just do the most incredible
stage that you've seen and go and just
have this amazing rapport with customers
and then they'll come back and like talk
about how they hate their stomach or
they wish their legs were smaller their
butt was bigger whatever it was and I'm
just like you don't see this power you
hold you don't see like how mesmerizing
you are to everybody else and I think
I think we all have this power it's just
like whether or not it's recognized and
it's not bad to recognize it it's really
beautiful to recognize great to
recognize it yeah and it can change your
life to just realize that you are
inherently magical just by [ __ ]
existing and putting up with the [ __ ]
you put up with
yeah even if your body isn't exactly
what you want it to be nobody's body is
exactly what they want it to be and
that's that's another thing I've
realized is there's these women around
me where I'm just like in my head this
idyllic bottle body type I've thought of
I'm seeing it it's right in front of me
and they [ __ ] hate it and I'm just
like okay then who possesses it yeah and
so I was just like all right [ __ ] that
I'm done hating myself because if I if
you can hate yourself in this stage and
every other stage and not realize what
you're holding then that means I'm
probably doing the same thing and that's
sort of what helped me realize like okay
I am beautiful I am sexy I am magnetic
it's just like realizing how many people
have these qualities and won't and
refuse to acknowledge it they act as if
it takes something away from them to
acknowledge it when they don't realize
it'll gift it'll give them gifts
the ability to love your body for
especially for a woman
comes before you achieve the body that
you want it has to like everyone's so
many people are women are thinking that
if I got this body I would love myself
exactly but I think the ability to love
yourself
is is what comes first it's an out of
body experience to love yourself and
then you'll end up loving the body that
you have or you'll end up being able to
achieve the body you want yeah much
easier than if you hate yourself hey you
can't hate yourself into loving yourself
exactly you cannot hate yourself into
loving yourself I read this thing not
too long ago and said if being hard on
yourself worked it would have worked by
now and that just like put me on my ass
for a minute when I read that because I
was just like that's it that's what it
is if it worked it would it doesn't work
to do that the only thing that works is
is love is to do it from a place of love
and wanting to be better only for
yourself
um I grew up I was heavier when I grew
up
um in high school I weighed about 220
pounds
um and
um I of course received hate for that as
a kid you know I got I was this kid once
bullied me in summer camp because it was
you know it was um like pool day and we
had a bunch of like water activities I
was wearing a bathing suit and he was
like making fun of me saying that I was
pregnant and that was one when I was you
know probably seven years old and so I
just received a lot of that type of talk
or just negative talk or just you know
women older than me saying oh you'd be
so beautiful if you lost weight and all
this [ __ ]
and um and then I lost weight I wasn't I
was trying to at first and then it just
kind of happened
um and then I developed a really
terrible eating disorder that I
struggled with for years
um and I didn't really get to a place
it was dancing really helped me conquer
that eating disorder
um
I um in what way
I just realizing food is fuel you can't
your body can't move well if it's if
it's hungry if it's hurting
um and just realizing how
rewarding food is
um I used to be a very emotional eater
when I was younger I needed to
constantly consume I was trying to
constantly like Comfort something inside
of me
um and then I got when it when it sort
of Switched I got like so full of I kept
saying like I was so full of love I was
so full of love but I was starving
myself and that wasn't love either
um and then I just sort of reached this
point where I learned to eat when I was
hungry and to honor that and to honor my
Cravings
um and the main thing I realized was
just like that's not
gonna change my body or my Wellness
overnight if I just eat something that
sounds good whatever it is
um and also just like really
de-centering fat phobia and like getting
rid of that in myself because I realized
I was so scared of being fat again and
gaining all this weight back and then I
realized that even if I did gain a bunch
of weight back and it did happen I for a
second for a while I was like 140 pounds
and then I went back up to
160 165
and I was fine nothing bad happened my
body just looked different in my opinion
it looked better
um and I was safe it was totally okay
and there was nothing the ground wasn't
like falling from under me and that
really helped me too was realizing okay
my weight can fluctuate and I can love
myself at all these stages and that's
okay too did you think that society and
women's magazines and social media
undermine women especially if your
generation's ability to love themselves
I think it predates on it I don't know
if it undermines it
um I think it just doesn't acknowledge
our ability to love ourselves
um and I think it counts on that it
absolutely relies on that in order to
make money I mean the beauty Industries
the I think the wealthiest industry that
exists and it's all because of attacking
women and how they feel about themselves
um and um
yeah I think those Industries rely on on
predating on women's ability to
recognize their own power
um
and it's it breaks my heart it makes me
really sad and I like that there are
more Progressive campaigns coming out
you know there are companies really
focusing on just like
feeling good about yourself and I think
that's really special and we need more
companies like that we really need to
like decenter this this idea of what
beauty is it's a very westernized it's
very starved it's you know
all these things that just aren't
healthy that are just sort of inherently
you know
evil almost you know yeah
what do you look forward to in your life
you're 23 you got your whole life ahead
of you I just look forward to getting to
know myself better and seeing what I'm
able to do
um I've really realized like how much
power I have through doing this and how
much of a draw I have and I realize I
can take that with me anywhere
um you know I don't I don't need the
reciprocity of men in order to have that
charm about me I have that whether or
not they're in the room
um and
I'm just excited to see what I can do
with that I don't know if I want to do
cannabis forever I just know it's an
Avenue that I'm really interested in
um but I'm interested in a lot of things
I know that I can you know do whatever I
end up wanting to do I think that I'm
really proud of myself for not
forcing myself to speed that process and
to just really meet myself where I am
and to not feel bad about setbacks I've
had or career choices whether that has
been the career of being a personal
assistant or being a stripper
um just really focusing on the forward
aspect of things helps
um but not rushing myself
um but yeah I'm excited to see what I do
with my life because I think it's going
to be cool that's great all right Josie
thank you so much for sharing your story
yeah thank you and uh it's nice to see a
young girl who's so confident with
yourself I hope we see more like that
thank you very much yeah thank you